[Music]
on this tuesday night putting political
interests
first a damning indictment from the
military ombudsman who says federal
political interference impedes progress
on sexual misconduct allegations
the erratic behavior of leadership
defies common sense
after decades of inaction will anything
change
the cleanup in quebec after a deadly
tornado rips through dozens of homes
plus the investigation into foreign
fighters in syria
why are the rcmp relying on reporting
from global news
to build their case and the nfl player
changing the game i actually hope that
like one day
videos like this and the whole coming
out process are just not necessary
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight with a scathing
assessment of the federal government's
inaction
on dealing with sexual misconduct in the
canadian military
it comes from the military ombudsman the
person tasked with making sure
service members are treated fairly
gregory lick says
internal mechanisms meant to support
victims of misconduct
have gone from broken to collapsed
enough is enough the cycle of scandals
followed by studies
recommendations for independent
oversight half solutions and resistance
by the department
or the canadian armed forces will only
be broken
when action is taken he can't take
action he says because vested political
interests complicate his ability
to do his work and he demanded his
office be granted true independence from
the federal government
our ottawa bureau chief mercedes
stevenson has our top
story tonight it is impossible to miss
the frustration
in gregory lick's voice the scandal has
put on display
a culture that insulates its bad actors
and demands
silence of its victims it's not often a
public watchdog
takes such clear and public aim at a
sitting government
leveling explosive allegations of
political interference
when leaders turn a blind eye to our
recommendations and concerns
in order to advance political interests
and their own self-preservation
or career advancement it is the members
of the defense community
that suffer these consequences canada's
military ombudsman says
he cannot do his job unless the office
has teeth
and independence from political agendas
of the day
an ability to speak directly to
parliament about abuses of power
corruption and sexual misconduct to
carry out
actual investigations and to hold the
military and government accountable
when they fail to act he's asking for
his office to report directly to
parliament
and i think that's appropriate for for
you know a free democracy
victims of military sexual misconduct
like colton skibinski
welcomed the ombudsman's recommendations
and appreciate his candor
we've had one ombudsman gary walborn
thrown under the bus
for doing the right thing and now we
have another one who says
i'm not going to get thrown under the
bus
i'm going to say it like it is and and i
have a lot of respect for that
gary walborne the ombudsman who tried to
hand an allegation to defense minister
harjeet sajin in 2018
is not surprised gregory lick appointed
by the trudeau government
has run into similar stonewalling and
obstructionism
it was only a matter of time until the
frustration level reached where mine was
and those who came before me
for an ombudsman to accuse the current
government of political interference
and protecting their own careers over
service members is
a very damning accusation the prime
minister
is still making promises we will be
making significant changes
to the way the military functions in the
coming
coming months as madame arbor
begins to make recommendations concrete
this prime minister
and this minister of defense have zero
credibility on this issue
while lick said he has not experienced
direct political interference
his report makes clear the fear of
reprisal is real
and let criticized the minister of
defense on delays in an action
which he said showed a lack of
ministerial accountability
in a statement the defense minister
harjeet sajin said he has always had a
professional working relationship with
the ombudsman
and that there has been no political
interference with his office
sajin also said lick had never contacted
him to say he felt there was a problem
mercedes the ombudsman said it is clear
inaction is rewarded far
more than actions so is any action
likely now
well donna that's the million dollar
question the government continues to say
they support
victims and promise action but they
won't give us a timeline
or any specifics on whether or not we'll
see that
independence with an election
potentially looming in the fall
the pressure is on to act quickly if
anything is going to get done
donna all right mercedes stevenson
in ottawa thanks now to quebec where a
powerful tornado touched down north of
montreal yesterday
this is the town of mascoche today in
the span of just a few moments
the tornado wreaked havoc here sweeping
through neighborhoods
tearing apart homes and leaving piles of
twisted debris
more than 60 homes were damaged or
completely destroyed
and one person a man in his late 50s was
killed
dan spector is in mascoche tonight dan
what are people telling you
donna people here 50 kilometers from
montreal are now assessing damage
picking up the pieces of their homes and
trying to reconcile feelings of shock
and disbelief
those who saw it monday afternoon could
hardly believe their
eyes this tornado packing winds
estimated between 180 and 200 kilometers
an hour brought
instant terror and destruction damaging
dozens of homes in a small neighborhood
and killing 59 year old grandfather
jacques lefevre as he tried to escape
he tried to go there but i don't think
then he had time to go inside
lefeve was michelle vachel's neighbor
they were working outside together when
the tornado formed
and sped toward them bashar managed to
get indoors his neighbor tried to hide
in an outdoor shed the same thing can
happen to me
i just have just little more you know
chance in him
lawn sets and pieces of homes blown
hundreds of meters
this house under construction totally
ruined as residents combed through the
debris
many came by still struggling to
comprehend it all
they never believed it could possibly
happen here
tornadoes you get that in kansas you
don't get that here
it was unbelievable the tornado
got stronger once it was on this street
and from
our from our windows we can see
it was black and only debris environment
canada investigators spent the day
assessing the damage to homes
fallen trees and power lines their
initial assessment
it was ef-2 on the fujita scale ef5
being the strongest the track at about
63
kilometers long from the city into the
the field there
environment canada did issue a severe
weather alert for the area as they were
tracking a thunderstorm
but the fast developing twister caught
scientists by surprise
they never issued a tornado warning for
the storm in mascoche
this one was really unpredictable there
wasn't any clear sign that it would
happen this way
while it still seems unreal to people
here in mass gush
tornadoes are not uncommon in quebec
officials say about seven touchdown in
the province each year
the last one that caused this much
damage was in gatineau in 2018.
donna all right dan specter in mascoche
quebec
thanks some good news about covet 19 in
quebec today premier francois lagos says
case counts have dropped and
vaccinations are up
so next monday the whole province will
move to the least restrictive green
alert level that means groups of 10 can
gather indoors
up to 20 people can gather in backyards
and restaurants and
starting this friday fully vaccinated
quebecers
will not need to wear masks at private
gatherings and outdoor festivals
of up to 3 500 people will be allowed
the national picture is also encouraging
on average about 900 new cases are being
recorded across the country
per day it is the first time since last
september the rolling weekly average of
new cases has dipped below
one thousand and the vaccination rate is
climbing
the government says more than 75 percent
of canadians 12 and up have now had at
least one dose
and over 20 percent are now fully
vaccinated
federal officials say it is still not
safe though to reopen canada's borders
to non-essential travel
some restrictions are lifting july 5th
but only for fully vaccinated canadians
entering the country
fully vaccinated foreigners are still
restricted
and the next steps and the benchmarks
that need to be met
are not being spelled out david aiken
reports
an angry opposition the government has
not produced a pathway to normalcy
especially for small businesses that
depend on an open border for tourism
it's time to follow the science and once
again begin the reopening for families
who have been separated for a long time
and for businesses who are struggling
to survive just explain to canadians
when the liberals will provide
benchmarks for lifting federal covet 19.
the honorable and a tourism industry
frustrated and
anxious about a potential lost summer
they're feeling desperate there's no
clarity on what
if any of the summer they're going to
have on monday the trudeau government
said
fully vaccinated canadians that follow a
health protocol
can travel back to canada and skip
quarantine and yet
fully vaccinated americans or other
foreign tourists
following the same health protocol are
still banned from canada
we're of the firm belief that a fully
vaccinated traveler is a fully
vaccinated traveler
regardless of nationality um and so
we're
not really understanding why we can't
open the border to our american
cousins prime minister justin trudeau
tried to explain the inconsistency
why a fully vaccinated american coming
from say
new york city is a bigger public health
risk
than a fully vaccinated canadian
traveler returning from new york city
being fully vaccinated against covet 19
protects you from the worst impacts
it does not necessarily
protect you from transmitting
and so the best comfort the prime
minister could offer to those whose
livelihood depends on tourism such as
the shopkeepers here on ottawa's famous
spark street mall or
to canadians who are waiting for a visit
from a family member overseas is
be patient the border rules might change
in a few weeks but the prime minister
offered no guarantee
donna all right david aiken thanks
adding new words to the citizenship oath
coming up long-awaited changes to the
ceremony
for new canadians
in two british columbia communities
there are mixed feelings about the
catholic churches burned to the ground
this week
both were part of first nations
communities places of worship for people
of
faith but also reminders of the role a
catholic church played in destroying the
lives of indigenous children
in residential schools police are
investigating the fires and residents
are feeling the loss robin gill reports
for 110 years sacred heart church stood
on land
belonging to the penticton indian band
until a fire destroyed it
chief greg gabriel grew up catholic as a
child he attended the church with his
family
but he has a complicated relationship
with religion
i could verse the whole catholic
mass in latin and not
my own language the congregation had
been dwindling but for those who
practice catholicism
it was a place for baptisms weddings and
funerals
the church and all those memories are
now gone a few hours later in nearby
oliver
saint gregory's church went up in flames
it was built in 1910 on land belonging
to the
soyuz indian band and whatever the
beliefs of the indigenous community
today
it has shaken them it's sad because
people still
need somewhere to pray the two fires
took place in the early hours of
national
indigenous day no one is saying there's
a connection yet
but leaders say it's time for
reconciliation to be expedited
we cannot go on with the crippling
legacy
of racialized violence
a sentiment shared by the penticton
indian band in light of the discovery of
grave sites at the former residential
school in kamloops
run by the church that anger is not
going to go away
and this is the result of the anger no
one is condoning the fires
but there's a feeling that the anger has
gone beyond the boiling point
robin gill global news vancouver ottawa
has made good on another call to action
from the truth and reconciliation
commission
31 new canadians were sworn in today
with a new oath of citizenship
it includes a line officially
recognizing the treaty rights of first
nations inuit and metis peoples
canada's first metis citizenship judge
suzanne
carrier led the new oath each and every
one of us has a role to play in healing
this country because reconciliation with
indigenous peoples
is a responsibility shared by all
canadians even new canadians
such as you're about to become
the change is in response to the 94th
call to action
in the truth and reconciliation
commission report six years ago
many others have not been acted on this
change received
royal assent last night on national
indigenous people's day
there we go you've done it
congratulations everyone you
are now
ahead the legal battles over canadians
left in syria accused of aiding the
islamic state
[Music]
it's been two years since the so-called
islamic state was finally
defeated in syria thousands of isis
foreign fighters along with their wives
and children
remain in legal limbo they are the
world's most
unwanted many are held in custody in
kurdish detention camps in northeastern
syria including
a number of canadians ottawa has so far
refused to repatriate them to face
charges here in canada
and the rcmp says it is too dangerous to
travel to syria to interview them
instead police are gathering evidence
from global news
jeff semple explains when this
isis propaganda film was posted online
in 2014
it shocked the world the 55-minute video
shows captured
syrian soldiers being executed and
observers also noted the isis narrator
sounded north american this harshness
never wavered and was a constant trait
of the brothers
for years no one including the rcmp
knew his identity but in october 2019
global news
traveled to syria to interview him
my goal was basically just to join the
fight in syria against the shock
his name is mohammed khalifa a former
i.t worker from toronto
captured by kurdish forces in 2019. in
an interview with global news reporter
stuart bell in syria
khalifa admitted to leaving canada to
join isis
there are at least 14 canadian adults
currently detained in syria
accused of fighting with the so-called
islamic state but unlike canada's allies
including the u.s and the uk
who have repatriated and prosecuted
their alleged foreign fighters the
canadian government has so far failed to
lay
a single criminal charge or bring any of
them home
but one month after global news
published its interview with khalifa
the rcmp demanded access to the
recording
global's lawyers argued that forcing it
to hand over the tape would put their
reporter at risk
and create a media chill by deterring
sources from speaking with journalists
global's lawyers also asked why further
efforts have not been made by the rcmp
to interview khalifa
themselves the rcmp argued it was simply
too dangerous for its investigators to
travel
to syria i think it is unfortunately a
convenient excuse
this national security law expert joined
global news on the trip to syria in 2019
she explains the rcmp's reluctance to
interview suspects in captivity overseas
by pointing to the case of canadian omar
cotter
in 2017 ottawa paid him 10 and a half
million dollars in damages after the
supreme court ruled canadian
investigators obtained evidence from
carter illegally
by interviewing him at guantanamo bay we
see potentially the exact same thing
here
the kurds detaining canadians who are of
interest to our security officials
in situations that are not compliant
with international
human rights obligations the tank
hunters have now paved the way for the
front-line stormers
but she says there's nothing preventing
the government from bringing khalifa and
other isis suspects home
to face interrogation and justice in
canada
and i think it's largely a political
decision they're worried about
bringing isis fighters back to the
country perhaps not being able to charge
some of them
in canada newly unsealed court documents
reveal the rcmp is preparing a case
against khalifa
they've interviewed his family in
toronto and obtained isis documents that
identify him
after an 18-month legal battle an
ontario judge
forced global news to hand over its
interview with khalifa to the rcmp
as investigators build their case
against a canadian
terror suspect in syria whom the
canadian government
refuses to bring home jeff semple global
news toronto
pride in the nfl next a deeply personal
revelation
from a football player
there is a wave of anger tonight after
european football's governing body
declined a request to have the stadium
in munich germany
lit up in rainbow colors for the match
against hungary tomorrow
it was to be a show of solidarity with
the lgbtq
community in hungary a country passed a
law which bans the display and promotion
of homosexuality to those under 18.
other stadiums in germany now intend to
show their colors and light up like
rainbows
tomorrow an nfl player with the las
vegas raiders is showing his colors
his name is carl nasib and he decided to
go public with the fact that he is gay
he says he agonized about the decision
for 15 years
eric sorenson explains why and what his
bold move means
for others defensive ends in football
are among the strongest athletes in
sports
but even at six foot seven two hundred
eighty pounds
carl nasib required an inner fortitude
and fifteen years of agonizing to say
this
just want to take a quick moment to say
that i'm gay i've been meaning to do
this for a while now
but i finally feel comfortable enough to
get it off my chest nasa becomes the
first active nfl player to announce he
is gay
like a dam bursting teammates opponents
and others tweeted support
the league itself saying the nfl family
is proud of you carl
the news of carl coming out the only
active player in any of the big four
professional leagues
it's big news it's a piece of history
while pro sports now promote
lgbtq2 inclusiveness openly gay athletes
like the nba's jason collins are still
exceedingly rare
the straight male culture especially in
team sports
remains unwelcoming brock mcgillis was
among the first pro hockey players to
come out while he played
that constant language that you hear
daily from the age of eight or nine
years old throughout your career
it just continues to beat it down in you
and that you
can't be you that's why i think it's so
critical that we humanize these issues
for players harrison brown is a
transgender man who played women's pro
hockey
the world of sports is still coming to
terms with the entire spectrum of lgbtq2
athletes
today's culture um in society it can
make it a scary space to be who you are
and being gay or being anything that's
not just a straight
white man is against is against the norm
for sport culture
a high profile athlete like nasib can
expect a backlash
online if not on the line of scrimmage i
actually hope that like one day
videos like this and the whole coming
out process are just not necessary
but for now it is in 2021 coming out
still requires courage eric sorensen
global news
toronto and that is global national for
this tuesday i'm donna friesen
tonight's air canada is the margaret bow
water park in corner brook newfoundland
and labrador
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
[Music]
[Applause]
bye-bye